سلام عليكم
ازيكم عاملين ايه
هسالكم سؤال حد عارف
ايه هي عقليه الضحيه
كم واحد عارف ايه هي عقليه الضحيه
اوكي حلو جدا
في يوم من الايام
كانت حياتي جميله جدا كنت مبسوط قوي لو اي
حد بص على حياتي من بره هيقول لحد مبسوط
قوي وحد سعيد جدا
كانت الدنيا معي سهله كنت ممكن اغير عربيه
كل شويه كنت ممكن اسافر براحتي
اوفر قل انا كنت مبسوط قوي وسعيد وعارف ان
انا لما اجي اتخرج ان انا هشتغل وهلاقي
شغل في شركه بترول والدنيا لطيفه جدا لحد
ما حصل حاجه في حياتي الحاجه دي خلت حياتي
تنقلب 180 درجه
بقى بالنسبه لي الحاجات اللي هي كانت معي
طبيعيه وسهله بقت بالنسبه لي حاجه صعبه
المنال جدا
ورفاهيه انا مش بحلم بها اصلا او بقيت صعب
ان انا احلم بيها خالص بسبب الظرف اللي
انا مريت به ده
ساعتها سبحان الله الواحد كان قدامه طريين
اول طريق ان انا
اخش
فيس او العقليه اللي هي بتاعه الضحيه دي
وهتكلم عليها يعني ايه اصلا وتاني طريق هو
هناجله كمان شويه مش هنقوله دلوقتي بس
السؤال هنا حد عارف ايه هي اصلا
عقليه الضحيه
عقليه الضحيه دي يا جماعه هو ان انا اصلا
حاسس ان انا مظلوم بسبب ظلم انا تعرضت له
فعلا او بسبب ظرف انا تعرضت له او حتى لما
اتعرض له انا حاسس على طول ان انا
انا مش مبسوط اصل حصل فيها كذا بس بتفضل
مطول فيها جدا واخد فيها
وقت كبير قوي قوي قوي قوي
طب هل عقليه الضحيه دي اصلا يا جماعه حاجه
بتحس بها شعور حلو ولا شعور مش حلو في
رايكم حلو ولا مش حلو
في ناس بتقول ان هي حلوه بس انا عايز اقول
لكم ان هي حلوه فعلا ليه طيب عقليه الضحيه
حلوه ليه اول حاجه
عشان انت بتلاقي ناس كتيره بتتعاطف معك
عشان انت بتعرف تتهرب من المسؤوليه بشكل
جميل جدا يعني ايه يعني اي حاجه حصلت لك
وانت دخلت مثلا بطوله معينه وما كسبتهاش
دخلت في الكليه امتحان وما نجحتش في
المدرسه ماده ما اتوفقتش فيها اللي بيحصل
معك ببساطه ما هو عشان المدرس ده هو السبب
ما بيفهمش ما هو عشان انا اصلا البطوله دي
كوسه خالص بس عمرك ما بتيجي تقول ما هو
انا عشان قصرت شويه ما هو انا عشان انا
فعلا ما ذاكرتش المذاكره اللي المفروض
اذاكرها
ما هو انا فعلا عشان ما كنتش واخد
الاستعداد بتاعي ان انا اخش الامتحان ده
كويس
فبتفضل مطول زائد ان انت بتلاقي ناس كتير
قوي فعلا بتتعاطف معك وبتعرف ان انت
تصطادهم كويس قوي
وتبدا ان انت تصطاد حد تاني او ضحيه تانيه
وبتحولهم اصلا بعد شويه ان هم يبقوا ناس
زيك وناس شبهك في الحته دي
في الحته دي فعلا مريحه قوي بس انت وانت
شغال في الحته دي بيبقى في لو انت فعلا
بقى ضميرك صاحي شويه حاجه بتقول لك ما
كفايه بقى خلاص اه يا سيدي انت حصل فيك
حاجه فعلا مش حلوه وحاجه مش كويسه انت
هتفضل بس هتفضل مكمل لحد امتى امتى بقى
هتقوم مكمل في حياتك ما الناس كلها خلاص
بيحصل لها ظروف وبيحصل فيها حاجات انت
هتفضل فعلا قاعد في الستيتس دي كتير قوي
في الوقت ده
انت بتلاقي نفسك ان انت مع الوقت بتلاقي
لان انت لقيت لوحدك خالص وبقيت
مش مبسوط باللي بيحصل عشان في واسع جواك
بيقول لك قوم شويه واتحرك وخد اي خطوه لك
في حياتك ساعتها انت بيبقى لك طريقين هكمل
في الطريق السهل اللي انا فيه ده اللي هو
اصلا مش سهل واصلا من سهل ظاهريا لكن من
جواك بيبقى متعب لو انت فعلا عندك ضمير
والطريق التاني اللي هو الطريق الصعب
الطريق الصعب ده هو ده الواقع فعلا وهي دي
الحياه الطبيعيه اللي ربنا قال عليها لقد
خلقنا انسان في الكبد يعني تعب وعناء
ومشقه وهو ده الطبيعي اصلا ان هي الدنيا
مش سهله ولو انت شايف ان الدنيا سهله
فانت عايش في وهم شويه خلي بالك وانا جاي
لك من المستقبل بقول لك لا الدنيا مش سهله
خالص
الطريق الصعب هو ان انت تبدا تاخد خطوه ان
انا هواجه هواجه يعني ايه
يعني انا ايه المشكله فين المشكله المشكله
عندي اه انا ما ذاكرتش كويس خلاص انا هبدا
اذاكر كويس المشكله ان انت ما فيش حد
هيساعدك اه ما فيش حد هيساعدك لان الناس
اصلا مش مطلوبه منهم ان هم ياخدوك من اللي
انت فيه ويخرجوك انت مسئول عن نفسك صعب في
ايه ان الدنيا بتاخد وقت عشان تقدر ان انت
تغير الوضع اللي انت فيه الوضع احسن هو ده
الصعب وهو ده الطريق فانت بتقرر ان انت
تاخد فعلا ده
طب ماشي حلو يعني انت بتقولي خلاص واجي اه
انا بقول لك واجي طب اعمل ايه لما اجي
اواجه
اول حاجه خطوات عمليه هقولها لك تقدر ان
انت هو ان انت ازاي تقدر تواجه التحديات
اللي ممكن تقابلك اول حاجه هي ان انت
تستعين بربنا سبحانه وتعالى جدا لان انت
داخل على حاجه هي مش سهله خالص فانت ما
تفتكرش ان هي هتبقى في شطارتك لا الموضوع
صعب ومتعب وبياخد وقت واي تحول بيحصل لكن
انت عايز ان انت مثلا كنت
مليان شويه وعايز تخس بياخد وقت مش سهل ان
انت عايز تغير
بتاعك لفاينينش الليفل اخر او مستوى مادي
معين لحاجه تانيه بياخذ وقت اللي انت عايز
ان انت وقعت هتبدا ان انت تقوم بكل ده
بياخد وقت ثاني حاجه عايز ان انت
تفهم معنى خطير قوي ان مش الشخص الناجح هو
اللي بيفضل ناجح على طول الشخص الناجح ده
هو اللي بيعرف لما يقع يعرف يقوم ثاني
فانت لما تيجي تقع وتقوم دي احسن مهاره
انت ممكن تتعلمها ان انا واحد بعرف اقوم
بعد اما اتخبط بعرف اقوم بعد اما اخد حاجه
في وشي لا انا هقوم وهكمل وانت في الموضوع
ده
هتلاقي سبحان الله ان في اكتر من ايد
بتتمد لك بعد ما انت مش لاقي حد يساعدك
هتلاقي ان الخطوه اللي انت بتاخدها بتلاقي
فيه باب بيفتح اكتر من باب هتلاقي ان
الشغل بيجيب شغل هتلاقي ان السعي ده من
افضل الحاجات اللي انت ممكن تحصل معك وان
انت هتفضل تتعلم حاجات كتير قوي في الطريق
اللي انت ماشي فيه بتاهلك عشان تبقى احسن
نسخه من نفسك بس قدام
تالت حاجه هتعملها ان انت يبقى عندك حاجه
اسمها التعلم الذاتي او السلف ليرننج
تعالوا بالذاتي في ايه يعني لو انت دلوقتي
واحد ما بتعرفش تذاكر خش على جوجل واكتب
ازاي اعرف اذاكر
وعايزك ان انت تبدا تقرا كتير جدا في
الحته دي وتخش في التفاصيل بتاعتها لو انت
راجل شغال في السيلز خش ازاي افضل ابيع
ازاي وتخش جوه جدا في التفاصيل بتاعتها لو
انا عايز ان انا اكسب في حاجه معينه افضل
اتعلم على جوجل جوجل بقى خلاص حاجه اكشن
انت بتعمله في حياتك ان انا لازم ادور على
قد ما اقدر
فتعالوا لركاب اللي اتقال ده كله تعالوا
نلخص اللي احنا قلناه اول حاجه ان الدنيا
اصلا مش سهله زي ما انت فاكر خالص الدنيا
صعبه جدا تاني حاجه الطريق السهل هو ان
انت تفضل عايش في دور الضحيه وعايش ان انا
اه ما انا مظلوم ما الدنيا صعبه ودي لذيذه
جدا اللي انت بتلاقي ناس تتعاطف معك تالت
حاجه الطريق الصعب وهو ده طريق الحياه
الحقيقيه مش ان الدنيا سهله وانت شايفها
دلوقتي ان الدنيا سهله بابا وماما كلهم
بيساعدوني الدنيا لطيفه لا الدنيا مش سهله
خالص هو اي حد هيساعدك هو هيحطك على
الطريق المهم ان انت تبدا ان انت تواجه
وتبدا ان انت تخش لو بدات تواجه وبدات تخش
هتتعرض لصعوبات كتيره جدا بس هتلاقي اكتر
من باب بيتفتح لك هتلاقي ان الشغل بيجيب
شغل هتلاقي ان ربنا هيكرمك اكتر ما كنت
ممكن تتخيل
شكرا